generative AI is the technology behind
the wave of new online tools used by
millions around the world
some can answer queries on a huge range
of topics in conversational language
others can generate realistic looking
photographs from short text prompts
as the technology is ever more widely
deployed what are its current strengths
and its weaknesses
The Economist science editor alot jar is
joined by Deputy editor Tom standage
Science correspondent Abby burticks and
Global business and economics
correspondent Arjun Romani to discuss
this new era of AI
Tom
The Economist has written about AI many
many times in various forms over the
years what's changed since the last time
we were really interested in it that
made it much better made AI much better
than perhaps it used to be what happened
in 2017 was that some researchers at
Google came up with a better retention
mechanism called the Transformer and
that's what the T in GPT stands for
um and so essentially that made these
systems a lot better they could sort of
come up with more longer pieces of
coherent output whether that's text or
computer code or whatever so there was a
technical breakthrough and um and that
took a while to Ripple uh through the
community so that's one of the things
that changed but the other thing that
changes this technology became much more
visible of course what happened last
year is that a much more capable model
GPT 3.5 was launched as chat GPT
literally as a chatbot which you know
anyone could sign up for and once you
got to the front of the waiting list you
could go and talk to it and you know
you'll have heard these numbers that 100
million people tried it within the first
two months and that's you know reckoned
to be the fastest adoption of a consumer
Tech technology and history so the thing
that really changed is that suddenly
there was a way that anyone could use
this technology and they came up with
all sorts of amazing uses for it and
asked it to do all sorts of
extraordinary things and that was what
really put it on the map I think one of
the huge strengths of these large
language models is that they're able to
kind of crunch and churn through such
like scads of unlabeled data so normally
like in the past with AI you always
needed like your thing and a label so
that required humans to kind of go
through and label them but these large
models you just you Chuck in the
internet and you get out of it a blurry
picture that is basically taken of
hundreds of billions of words
um and it honestly just seems to do well
I think a lot of people are still kind
of baffled why why it's doing so well at
so many tasks like it it generates
convincing text it's very good at
pattern matching style transfer is one
of the other things like you ask it to
like oh write a love letter in the style
of a pirate from The 14th Century that
has an Irish accent but is from like the
Bahamas and then it's also pretty good
at passing standardized tests it seems
like it passed the U.S medical licensing
exam it's passed some legal tests I'm
basically very good at kind of text
things at the moment I think uh you know
one of the big opportunities is writing
code the great thing about writing code
with these systems and and I do still
write some code
um is that if if the code is slightly
wrong you find out straight away because
uh you know either The Interpreter or
the compiler chokes on it or the output
of the code isn't quite what you were
expecting so you had this very tight
feedback loop
um and uh if it's slightly wrong you
find out you find out pretty quickly in
terms of weaknesses I I think one of
them is the lack of transparency like
it's kind of a black box we you can have
access to kind of what's going inside
the attention weights what those values
are but they don't mean a lot to us
um there's over a hundred billion of
these weights and that's very very
complex and hard for us to understand
and what they're doing
um and so yeah I think the main weakness
is that it's such a complex system and
we don't really understand it fully if
your job is to find out new facts that's
actually not something of these systems
are really in a good position to do and
I was talking to people
um within the uh the foreign office the
British government the other day and
also they will say what's the impact of
this and I would say look our job of
whether we work in government or the
intelligent services or journalism is to
find new facts and um and they've got to
be right right and you've got to you you
really don't want to just take any old
stuff coming out of one of these systems
so if the accuracy matters then these
systems are you know maybe not so great
the reliability of the models need to be
improved I think before for you know
they start automating huge amounts of
processes and businesses
um but I mean there's a huge amount of
uh economic activity I think that'll get
affected by this I mean the paper put
out by some economists at open AI that
said that you know around 20 of the US
Workforce uh could have around 50 of
their tasks affected by by generative AI
in the next few years right so a lot of
tasks that we do on a day-to-day basis
um could be helped by these models over
over the long term but there's some
interesting uh you know research in the
economics of innovation that talks about
how if you want to get uh what we call
an intelligent explosion or if you want
to get uh you know exponentially
increasing rates of economic growth
um in any given domain uh you need to
automate the entire process if you've
only automated you know 90 of it or 99
of it uh that doesn't get you uh nearly
the same the same effect
um because the the slowest part of the
process which is maybe probably the
human acts as what's called a rate
determining step so we will end up
slowing things down so I think that's
probably uh you know what is likely to
happen in my mind where you know we use
AIS to help us uh with research which
frankly we are already doing
um but it it still is not able to get
100 of the way there so ultimately the
pace of progress continues
um as it has been so they they would
have become super intelligent intended
into paper clips if it wasn't for those
pesky humans getting in the way and
making them more intelligent this is an
excerpt from a 45-minute discussion
about the risks and opportunities of AI
Economist subscribers can watch the
exclusive event in full by clicking on
the link